but first we're a little over 12 hours
until folks start organizing to the
Nevada caucuses and it looks like
Democrats could be facing a repeat of
the fiasco we saw in Iowa two weeks back
if you can believe it
experts are warning of potential
technical snafus now the dancy already
voided 1000
ed party chair Tom Perez he told the AP
he won't commit to same-day election
results oh is this are we a third world
country we can't announce the election
results the night of the election I
guess we have not computers anymore I
guess not hand counting but the counting
chaos is besides the point now the real
question of the Nevada caucuses is this
do they even matter Bernie is sure to
win tomorrow and after that the order of
finishes don't make that much of a
difference and I feel confident
declaring tonight that this race is
shaping up to be a two-man show Sanders
versus Bloomberg despite that horrific
debate performance Wednesday night now
as the saying goes follow the money
The Wall Street Journal is reporting
that Peabody jej and Joe Biden have not
invested in any ads in the crucial Super
Tuesday states while Amy Klobuchar and
Elizabeth Warren combined have put in
less than two million into Super Tuesday
ads that's nothing it's like grocery
store circulars in other words they're
just running out of cash running out of
money running out of town time which
Bernie through his grassroots army and
bloomie through his own personal
finances they have the money in spades
now on top of fundraising know the
biggest tell for who the front-runner
sees as his real threat is whom they
attack now Bernie will use his Sunday 60
Minutes interview to take direct aim now
at one person and one person only Mike
Bloomberg I think it's quite likely the
Trump will chew him up and spit him out
if you were worried about him before you
less worried now after having that
debate I am worried about an
unprecedented amount of money being
spent on a campaign
and you know we've never seen anything
like this in American history for
Bloomberg well the feeling of antipathy
is mutual I worry that we may very well
be on the way to nominating somebody who
cannot win in November and if we choose
a candidate who appeals to a small base
like senator Sanders it will be a fatal
error
well after Nevada the Democratic primary
race moves to South Carolina
now that state was supposed to be Joe
Biden's firewall but as bite as lead
shrinks in the Palmetto State Bloomberg
is reportedly telling his rich friends
to stop giving money to Biden's campaign
and just slowly let the patient bleed
out well South Carolina could end up
being Uncle Joe's last stand that is if
he even makes it there